there is no more iconic landscape of the
American West the Monument Valley and
there's no animal more symbolic than the
horse monument across ninety-two
thousand acres of Navajo Nation across
Utah and Arizona
[Music]
the Navajo tightly control who can
access it they're very very good
stewards of the valley that also means
you can't just go anywhere and do
anything the best way to see it by far
is by horse if you go in vehicle you're
restricted to certain roads but if you
go with a Navajo guide you can go
anywhere that they'll take you
[Music]
Navajo weren't the first people to live
in Monument Valley the Anasazi were
there thousands of years ago and they've
left traces on some of the Red Rock you
can actually find their petroglyphs and
pictographs
[Music]
not a lot of people know it but about
eight or nine families actually live in
Monument Valley if you're lucky you'll
get a guide who will take you to visit
one of those we got to meet a woman
named Effie yahzee and her mom Susie
Susie only speaks Navajo she appeared in
some of the early John Ford westerns my
mom has been living here she was born in
the valley and I was born here in the
valley too
well I'm doing is um weaving a rug and
so the two of them living without
running water without electricity are
raising their own sheep shearing them
spinning the wool and making rugs we got
to experience exactly what that whole
process looks like hey how long is your
family lived in London all their life
SmartPak is as for mecca is probably
about five generation Matt my mom loves
it here because she says this is where
my home is I love it here too it's just
a white opening you can clean alone
around the rocks you can hear your echo
all around and and I just love that
no animal is more symbolic of the
American West than the horse and the
Navajo have been known for their
horsemanship for several hundred years
so a trip to Monument Valley in the
saddle it's not just an adventure but it
might be one of the purest American
adventures of all
[Music]